It's another day in Trump's America and therefore
another one of these just horrifying dystopian
authoritarian incidents to tell you about, Donald
Trump has fired the head of cybersecurity for the
Department of Homeland Security. Why? Because
the head of former head of cybersecurity
said there was no widespread voter fraud, directly
implying Joe Biden really did win. Donald Trump
really did lose. We call this reality. We call
this the facts. We call this living in the real
world, but unfortunately doesn't work if you work
for Donald Trump. I'm talking about Christopher
Krebs, the director of the Cybersecurity and
Infrastructure Security Agency. This is part
of the Department of Homeland Security. He
reportedly expected to be fired. Consider
that for a second. This president's capricious
nature and complete intolerance to what are to him
inconvenient truths. It's so widely known that
his head of cybersecurity expected to be fired
for saying the results are real. Joe Biden really
won. There was no widespread voter fraud. He
anticipated that, saying that would get him fired.
And the sequence here was that Krebs, his agency,
put out a statement saying, we've looked at
all of the allegations and we find no evidence
of voter fraud in the 2012 election. And the
statement included a section that said, quote,
The November 3rd election was the most secure in
American history. Right now, across the country,
election officials are reviewing and double
checking the entire election process prior
to finalizing the result. When states have
close elections, manual recount ballots,
all of the states with close results in the 2012
presidential race have paper records of each vote,
allowing the ability to go back and count
each ballot if necessary. This is an added
benefit for security and resilience. This process
allows for the identification and correction of
any mistakes or errors. There is no evidence that
any voting system deleted or lost votes, changed
votes or was in any way compromised. Of course,
Trump's entire case that he won is based on all
sorts of claims of exactly what Christopher
Krebs said. There is no evidence of fraud,
observers being blocked, votes flipping, votes
being deleted via voting machine manipulation.
It's the full gamut that Trump has alleged,
and it's the full gamut that Christopher Krebs
said it didn't happen. Christopher Krebs putting
out a statement saying none of those things
happened and Donald Trump fires him. Donald Trump
then tweeted about this firing, saying, quote, The
recent statement by Chris Krebs on the security
of the 2020 election was highly inaccurate in
that there were massive improprieties and fraud,
including dead people voting that's been debunked,
poll watchers not allowed into polling locations.
There were Republican and Democratic poll watchers
everywhere, glitches in the voting machines,
which changed votes from Trump to Biden. No
evidence of that late voting and many more. No
evidence of late voting. Of course, as long as you
vote by Election Day, votes can be counted as they
arrive after the fact. And then he goes on to say,
therefore, effective immediately, Chris Krebs has
been terminated as director of the Cybersecurity
and Infrastructure Security Agency. There is no
evidence of any of the things Donald Trump is
alleging. These are the things that Donald
Trump and his cronies have been claiming.
But courts and election officers have
so far not found merit to these claims.
And indeed, these tweets were flagged by Twitter
as being disputed. Claims about election fraud.
It's starting to seem like disputed might not
be a strong enough flag for Twitter. I mean,
the things that Donald Trump is tweeting,
there's no evidence for them. It's it's
not merely disputed. It's like if I said humans
actually breathe helium, not oxygen, and it pops
up. This is a disputed claim about science. Well,
it's more than disputed. It's completely vapid.
There's no evidence for it whatsoever. But in
any case, Twitter flags aside, after being fired,
Chris Krebs tweeted, simply honored to serve.
We did it right. Defend today, secure tomorrow.
At this point, is being fired by Trump simply for
doing your job, a sort of badge of honor? Because,
you know, we've been talking about so many of
these hangers on around Donald Trump who have done
his lying and his bidding and his disinformation
spreading. They really deserve to never work
again. Kayleigh McEnany is an example. We'll talk
about her later. People like Corey Lewandowski,
you know Steve Bannon. These are people who,
if we had a fair world where actions had
fair consequences, they would never work again.
Now, I'm not calling for anybody to starve.
They should all have enough to eat
hell. They should even have health care.
But what I'm saying is that their malfeasance is
so severe that they should be unemployable by any
moral right thinking employer. OK, on the they
probably will all get great consulting gigs or
media gigs or who knows what. On the other hand,
you have people who simply are doing their job,
like, for example, Chris Krebs is in
charge of analyzing whether the election
took place in a secure fashion or whether there
was the widespread fraud that has been alleged.
He did his job. He looked at it. There's no it's
not even being asserted that Chris Krebs was
politically influenced or strongarmed by someone
or part of some conspiracy to falsely give the
election to Joe. It's not even being alleged
in any serious way. Maybe some on the Internet
are alleging that. But it's it's not even an
allegation. He simply did his job. And this is
the conclusion he came to and he was fired. He was
just. You're fired. That's it. You're just gone.
Is that now? I mean, have we fallen so far that
that that is now a badge of honor or some kind?
These are bizarre times that we are living
in. And hopefully at a certain point
we will get back to a status quo that makes
a little bit more sense right now. It really
doesn't. And it's horrifying. Our I don't want
to say our current allies, because some of them
are distanced at this point because of the
Trump presidency. But our historical allies
are regularly horrified by what is going on in
this country. We have to start writing the ship.
And hopefully I mean, listen, I I'm not going
to tell you it will happen, but hopefully the
replacement of Donald Trump with Joe Biden will
be a start to that, an inflection point of sorts.